hi in this sample I will demonstrate how
to use the apigee maven deploy plugin to
deploy a proxy from your source code to
apigee using Cloud build
apogee Maven plugin is a tool for
building and deploying the apigee API
proxy bundles into your apigee platform
and Cloud build is a fully managed
continuous integration delivery and
deployment platform that lets you run
fast consistent and reliable automated
bills
now the prerequisites for this sample
are you should have an apigee X
provisioned and configure external
access for API traffic
as a user you will need access to deploy
proxies to apigee and also trigger Cloud
build job in your gcp project
along with that you will need to have
tools like gcloud unzip curl GQ and npm
installed now this sample can be
demonstrated using the cloud shell
QuickStart tutorial or following the
setup instructions in this video we will
use the cloud shell QuickStart
click the open in Google Cloud shell to
open the cloud shell environment and
once the environment is completely
loaded let's follow the instructions
provided in the tutorial
now that I have my environment
completely provisioned and ready to use
let's follow the instructions that we
have on the tutorial on the very right
now the first thing that we will have to
do is make sure that we have our
environment set up for that let's
do gcloud auth login
yes it's going to ask me to go through
the login process
I love
I copy the
authorization code I am pasting it here
and that's pretty much it
next we'll have to navigate to the
deploy
apigee proxy directory which I just did
and then I can click here to open the
env.sh file so here are some
configurations that we'll have to update
uh in order to get this sample deployed
to our project so the first thing that
we will need is the the project ID
second that we will need is the apigee
host this is the apigee host the domain
that you would configure in your
environment group and then the
environment where you'd want to deploy
this now let me replace those values on
my configuration file
and let's make sure that we save it
once this is saved let's Source this
environment.sh file
now that we've done all of the required
step let's click Start
now the next step that we will have to
do is make sure that we have enabled
Cloud build API in this project so let's
click this and click enter
now it's enabled now the next step that
we will have to do is make sure that the
cloud build service account
has the apigee admin role to deploy the
proxy to your apigee Arc
so we've enabled it through the gcloud
command next is triggering the gcloud
build through this Cloud command
where we pass the apigee environment
that we want to be using to push the
proxy input
now this is going to take a few minutes
meanwhile let's take a quick look at the
cloud build.dml now this Cloud build
yaml is a very simple file that first
generates a token second it it basically
packages the bundle which is taking the
entire code and creating a bundle dot
zip file and at the end it deploys it so
it's all through the maven Palm file
that is available as part of the code
once this is complete you should be
seeing a status that's a success and
then if you go through the tutorial
again you will see that at the end of
the cloud build trigger a proxy must be
deployed uh to apigee called sample
hello cicd now let's login to the apigee
console to make sure that we see that
proxy
yes I see a sample hello cicd proxy
deployed a minute ago let's go back and
see if the proxy is working as expected
so we have a sample call command here so
let's copy that and let's make a few
calls
you should be able to see the calls
coming in
of that explains the sample of how to
how to basically deploy
an apigee proxy from your source code to
apigee using the maven plugin and Cloud
build now that we've had this please
rate this tutorial and if you want to
clean up this particular assets that
we've just clear created just go ahead
and run the cleanup deploy apigee
proxy.sh this will make sure that it
goes and it deletes the sample proxy
that we just created you'll see that's
deleted
thanks for watching I hope this content
was useful to you if you have not signed
up for apigee yet use this link and if
you have any questions please visit the
apigee community